YESTERDAY WAS THE START OF MARCH
MADNESS -- NCAA SELECTION
SUNDAY.
ACTUALLY, FOR ME, EVERY SUNDAY
IS SELECTION SUNDAY, IN THAT I
"SELECT" TO IGNORE MY LOVED ONES
AND WATCH SPORTS ALL DAY, AND
APPARENTLY I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE
DISTRACTED BY THIS MARCH TO
MADNESS.
>> MARCH MADNESS IS A
PRODUCTIVITY KILLER FOR
COMPANIES.
A REPORT ESTIMATES DISTRACTED
WORKERS COULD COST AT LEAST
$1.9 BILLION IN WAGES AS PEOPLE
FILL OUT THEIR BRACKETS IN THE
OFFICE AND MANY GAMES WILL BE ON
DURING THE DAY.
BUT EXPERTS SAY EMPLOYERS
SHOULDN'T BAN OFFICE POOLS
BECAUSE IT COULD HURT MORALE.
>> Larry: YEAH, THAT SOUNDS
LIKE FUN!
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE AN OFFICE
POOL!
>> DID SOMEBODY SAY OFFICE
POOL?!
SWEET!
CANNONBALL!
>> Larry:, NO, NO, NO
THAT'S NOT THE TYPE OF POOL I
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SHOO!
GO ON!
GET!
DAMN NEIGHBORS' KIDS.
BUT BACK TO BASKETBALL.
NOTHING SOOTHES MY NERVES LIKE
AMATEUR ATHLETICS, WHERE IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE MOLDING OF YOUNG
MINDS, FAR FROM THE CORRUPTING
INFLUENCE OF MONEY.
>> NCAA BASKETBALL WHICH
GENERATES ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR MARCH
MADNESS --
>> COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE
GENERATING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF MONEY --
>> THIS NEW PLAYOFF STRUCTURE
HAS GENERATED MILLIONS, MAYBE
EVEN BILLIONS IN EXTRA REVENUE
FOR SCHOOLS.
>> Larry: OKAY, SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF MONEY CHANGING
HANDS.
A FEW BILLION HERE OR THERE.
BUT THE MONEY IS ALL STAYING
WITHIN THE HALLOWED HALLWAYS OF
THESE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS,
RIGHT?
>> THE CURRENT CONTRACT FOR
MARCH MADNESS WITH CBS AND
TURNER BROADCAST IS FOR HOW MANY
YEARS AND HOW MUCH MONEY?
>> 14 YEARS AND IT'S
$10.8 BILLION.
>> $10.8 BILLION?
>> Larry: WHAAAAA?!
$10.8 BILLION?
MAN, I COULD REALLY MAKE IT RAIN
WITH THAT!
>> OH, IT'S RAINING?
DOES THAT MEAN THE POOL'S
CLOSED?
>> Larry: THERE'S NO POOL!
GO ON!
GET!
(APPLAUSE)
THERE'S NO POOL.
ALWAYS KEEP A STICK HANDY IS
WHAT I SAY.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY JUST TO
AIR THE TOURNEY.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT NATIONAL AND REGIONAL
CABLE DEALS, TICKET SALES AND
MERCHANDISE.
SO WHO GETS THIS PILE OF MONEY
THAT EVEN OPRAH WOULD THINK IS
OBSCENE?
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND, I HAD MY
RESEARCH TEAM MAKE THIS HANDY
PIE CHART.
HERE WE SEE THE $10.8 BILLION.
NOW, HERE IS ALL THAT IS LEFT OF
THE PIE WHEN YOU TAKE AWAY WHAT
THE PLAYERS ARE PAID.
WOW!
ODD?
ONLY $10.8 IS LEFT FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES AND THE NCAA
ITSELF.
HOW DO THEY STAY AFLOAT?
GOOD WORK, GUYS!
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE OUR PIE
CHART TEAM TO THE FOLKS AT
U.S.A. TODAY IF WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL.
>> IT WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY SHINE
THE SPOTLIGHT ON THE AGE-OLD
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
COLLEGE ATHLETES SHOULD BE PAID
"DOLLARS" FOR PLAYING.
>> Larry: BUT SERIOUSLY, WHY
DO COLLEGE ATHLETES NEED
"DOLLARS"?!
THEY'RE GETTING PAID IN
EDUCATION!
IT'S MORE LIKE "BRAIN BUCKS"
THAT THEY CAN REDEEM AT THE
"KNOWLEDGE STORE" TO BUY "WISDOM
POINTS"!
AND THOSE WISDOM POINTS WILL
HELP THEM HAVE PERSPECTIVE WHEN
THEY ARE "HOMELESS" BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY "ACTUAL MONEY."
(APPLAUSE)
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE SYSTEM WAS
DESIGNED TO KEEP ATHLETES POOR.
>> THE WHOLE IDEA OF A STUDENT
ATHLETE WAS DEVELOPED AS A LEGAL
TERM TO PREVENT THE WIDOW OF A
PLAYER FROM COLLECTING WORKERS'
COMPENSATION.
THE ARGUMENT BY THE NCAA IS WAIT
A MINUTE, THEY'RE NOT WORKERS,
THEY'RE STUDENT ATHLETES.
THEREFORE, WE OWE THEM NOTHING.
>> Larry: REALLY, NCAA?
IS THAT REALLY THE SLOGAN YOU
WANT FOR YOUR COLLEGES?
"WE OWE THEM NOTHING"?
REGARDLESS OF HOW THE STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE BEING TREATED, IT'S
NOT STOPPING ANYONE FROM FILLING
OUT THEIR BRACKETS.
EVEN THE PRESIDENT HAS BRACKET
FEVER.
GOOD LORD!
CAN WE STOP WITH THE BRACKETS,
ALREADY?
NO, WE CAN'T, WHICH IS WHY IT'S
TIME FOR THE COOLEST BRACKET
GAME EVER BRACKETED IN
BRACKET-TOWN.
HIT IT.
>> DARE-Y WILMORE'S MARCH
BADNESS BRACKETSBALL,
DARE-O-MANIA 2-15! IT'S BONER
TIME!
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.
NO JOKES.
SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
I'VE ASSIGNED MYSELF A DARE FOR
EVERY TEAM IN THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT.
THAT'S RIGHT, 68 TEAMS, 68
DARES.
EVERY TIME A TEAM WINS, THAT
DARE ADVANCES -- ALL THE WAY TO
THE CHAMPIONSHIP, WHICHEVER TEAM
WINS IS THE DARE I WILL HAVE TO
DO ON THIS SHOW.
NOW, THIS IS ABSOLUTELY REAL.
WE'RE NOT MAKING THIS UP.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE SOUTH
REGIONAL DIVISION, IF EASTERN
WASHINGTON WINS THE TOURNAMENT,
I'LL HAVE TO RIDE A HORSE
SHIRTLESS LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'LL DO IT!
BUT IF GEORGETOWN WINS, MY EVIL
TWIN WILL HOST THE SHOW.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT WILL BE
LIKE.
IT WILL BE FUN.
AND, OF COURSE, THE BETTER THE
TEAMS, THE HARDER THE DARES.
IF NUMBER FOUR SEED MARYLAND
GOES ALL THE WAY, I'LL BE FORCED
TO WEAR A BOSTON CELTICS JERSEY
FOR THE ENTIRE SHOW.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
AND I HATE THE CELTICS.
AND IF KENTUCKY TAKES THE CROWN,
I'LL BE BABY BIRDED, WHICH MEANS
SOMEONE WILL HAVE TO CHEW UP
SOME FOOD AND FEED IT INTO MY
MOUTH.
WHICH I'D PREFER TO WEARING A
STUPID CELTICS JERSEY.
(APPLAUSE)
THE BRACKET WILL FILL UP WITH
DARES ALL THIS WEEK.
THE FIRST 32 ARE UP NOW AT
TheNightlyShow.com/Dares, AND
WE WANT YOU TO HELP US FILL IN
THE REST. BE AS DARING AS YOU
WANT. IF IT MAKES IT THROUGH, I
GOTTA DO IT
SO TWEET US YOUR DARES WITH THE
HASHTAG "DARELARRY," AND I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING AN ASS OF
MYSELF FOR YOU.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK!
♪♪
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)